[Applause]
[Music]
summer break might be ending but if you
want to skip your first few classes
there are plenty of games to keep you
occupied I mean do you really need to
spend like an hour going over your
biology 101 syllabus
wouldn't you rather boot up your
Nintendo switch or your PC hit that
subscribe button
and you'll know all about the hottest
games for those platforms and more when
new releases goes live every Sunday now
here are some of this week's finest
selections we'll start off with the
Nintendo switch what do you get when you
cross Super Mario with Rabbids well you
get Mario plus Rabbids Kingdom battle
and if you guess that it's a turn-based
game kind of like a cartoon
XCOM give yourself a pat on the back
Mario Luigi peach Yoshi and for Rabbids
dressed up like them have to restore the
Mushroom Kingdom after it collides with
the Rabbids universe you'll have to make
good use of your weapons cover and
special skills to get through every
stage when Kingdom battle releases on
Tuesday August 29th and if you want a
good look at one of the Rabbids costumes
before then why not check out our
unboxing video when you think about
fighting strategically you might picture
yourself going through every step of
your combo and that's exactly what you
have to do in absolve err the combat
here is like dancing where your attacks
and dodges have to be precise to take
down your opponent each move is based on
a card so building the right deck is key
you'll collect more of those cards plus
weapons and armor as you explore the
world fighting alongside or against
other players if you're up for the
challenge you can take a swing at
absorber on ps4 Xbox one and PC on the
29th if you've heard the name
Windjammers before that was probably in
the 90s and now the cult classic Neo Geo
game is being brought into the modern
age the game is still simple you've got
to throw the frisbee into your
opponent's goal but now you can take the
competition online complete with ranked
matches you can choose a character serve
slide and return the frisbee on ps4 and
Vita
on the 29th now if they would just add a
volleyball mode as DLC then we could
recreate some very important movie
moments
[Music]
let's move away from the beach to the
mean streets of Yakuza cooiiy
if you played Yakuza zero earlier this
year you'll be able to jump right in
since Kewanee is an HD remake of the
very first game in the series
that means Kira's story looks and runs
better and thanks to some extra story
content it even flows better with some
of the more confusing plot points ironed
out
Yakuza kwame comes to western ps4 is on
the 29th and finally if you want to
literally go back to school this week
you can revisit Blackwell Academy with
life is strange before the storm as the
name implies this is a prequel to the
time-traveling choose-your-own-adventure
game putting you in Chloe prices shoes
earlier versions of characters like
Rachel amber also make an appearance and
you'll be able to interact with them
using the series usual dialogue trees
episode 1 of this three-part story kicks
off on ps4 Xbox one and PC on August
31st and those are some of the hottest
games we'll be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with another batch
of games next week